less than a month after chinese
president xi jinping met vladimir putin
russia's leader launched the most
aggressive attack in europe for decades
but china's leaders have refused to
condemn the invasion or use the word
invasion at all
the ukrainian issue has other very
complicated historical background today
it may not be what any of us want so we
hope that all parties will work together
to give peace a chance
china is criticizing both the united
states for exacerbating tensions and
nato for ignoring what it says are
russia's legitimate security concerns
china also says sanctions are
ineffective and only harm the general
population china feels very strongly
that the u.s is trying to encircle it
and contain it
russia feels the same way
the combined pressure on both of them
has pushed them together and there's no
question about that so at this juncture
they feel that they're up against
the u.s and its allies beijing has
repeated its claims of non-interference
in the affairs of other countries
it won't provide moscow with military
support but it has been bolstering trade
such as increasing imports of russian
wheat
you don't go and throw a lifeline to
russia in the middle of a period when
they're invading another country that is
simply unacceptable but this doesn't
mean china condones russia's attack on
ukraine it also has good ties with kiev
and relies on strong trade with europe
beijing must balance its friendship with
moscow while maintaining relations with
the west for the sake of its long-term
economic and strategic interests
where china clearly supports moscow in
terms of trade and economics and in
ideology but won't actually you know
kind of violate western sanctions um
you know to to to to physically help i
think that situation will remain and
that's what moscow expects on the same
day russian forces invaded ukraine nine
chinese fighter jets entered taiwan's
air defense zone
some analysts have drawn comparisons
between ukraine and the self-ruled
island claimed by china a link chinese
officials deny katrina you al jazeera
beijing